[Laughter]
that's not how i thought
you're going to make the game weight so
i don't do the thing that enrages you
which i don't know what that is but i
assume i would do it accidentally yeah i
want to avoid that thing
yeah come on invite your audio still do
the nonsense or
no no okay cool wow why didn't it really
fix
everything yxlr i love you so
much i threw money at the problem and
the problem went away
do we have to do rayman and no one said
we had one you can do regular uno
yeah what is that regular plain old oh
you want to do regular uno regular uno
just why does it have to be weird just
heck it doesn't
can you stop cursing my monetization
listen you're not started yet you're not
on your intro i i don't do my intros
uh hello everybody
all right cool good you know that's fine
can i get in the gosh darn game
oh that's right my picture is me
flicking you off oh i forgot
my monetization maybe it's my pointer
fingers you can't see most of my hand
maybe i have simpsons
i might have three fingers on my hand
well unless you have your wedding band
on your middle finger and your pinky
finger is cut off
yeah no that's it that's okay all right
that's fair that
that's fair it's not it's not offensive
it's just like look at my brain
look at my big brain look at my huge
head
all right brain head not another head
not the pain
i wasn't even thinking peanut guys i
want to make money on this
guys i wasn't even thinking of the penis
head okay stop it
i need i'm just stopping
i got money on my mind i've got money
in the bank right okay
what what was that was that was that
supposed to be like old town road
[Music]
i love that song california
no that's not it i think that was it
hello
i'm gonna wait no you can you can go now
you did me a huge favor because i don't
have any of those cards so i'm going to
oh wow i bob what color you want i'll
give you that
it doesn't really matter does it all
right it matters
wait wait hang on wait wait wait a
minute nikes
wait a minute wait i'd challenge that if
i were you you got come-ups
no don't challenge it wrecked
yeah i lost the challenge guys just so
you know if you didn't notice it
get him i'll get him laid here get him
away
fetch him ready go go get that snack i'm
gonna get this
full hand nice oh yeah
so sick yeah all right oh good
um well that's oh i could have jumped in
and saved you bob i didn't want to
skip your thanks buddy i didn't know you
didn't have any blue oh there we go
yellow
all right cool now someone's gonna pay
for it here we go
oh my friend i know right
oh so bob you've never been my friend
okay that hand is terrible it's not
going to be always better
all right wait hang on no one's my
friend mark you've always been my well
never mind
all right here we go so cool mark i
don't like you anymore
what's wrong with me don't do anything
to you
i'm so mad at you mark i'm gonna do that
why oh just because i knew that would
happen
hey gotcha gotcha you
dirty dirty ai dare curse
i didn't i stopped myself for you thank
you
you're just making lixian do work that's
all you're doing
oh after me no after you well that's not
so good that's not good for me either if
i'm being honest
no my heart hey shopper
calm down with that oh boy oh man
oh i can't i can't do anything about
that i can do something about this
all right oh my chopper my man
uh wow that's just rude chopper that's
what happened
you don't have the barbara we'd get the
chance
to do a little dance what happened to
all the cards that just make the game
all
all crap and i know completely late
why is this like this wade who did this
you wouldn't like wade when he angry i
could jump in on myself
i can
why didn't it i was click i was clicking
it jump in on this
bob that's so rude
oh gosh diddly darn i got this one at
least
wait so are we full are we are we not
supposed to curse
well i mean i'm bad for monetization yes
it is
yes it is if you do any cursing at all
straight up booger snatcher how how
light
how lightweight does it have to be that
sounds like in certain lights that
sounds bad but i guess that's okay but
it was that's that's that's a pg
pantsless monkey of mine oh
how many times do i have to kiss you oh
you you freaking oh one more time
one more time you
you apple that fell off the tree
[Applause]
you mustache wearing
wendy's window assistant yeah that's
what it's called you
large poured uh
red-nosed freak whoa whoa that's harsh
man freaking oh
you left me no choice but to play
this five you
showed me man just
facial my brain was like don't say just
five don't say just
five i looked up and then was
was was showered with that one
hey you you
you pickle pusher
red-haired truck little driver
you did it again you you long-necked
whoever's getting this ear wax eater
this is hard you know what bob here's
what i think of our friendship
oh you small footed
bunch budger oh you
hey don't even oh you would you
you flappy eared nipple squeezer
that's right it was all part of my
perfect ploy to take your card
i'm really bad at this what
you know how it removes you you know
whose line is it anyway
that's a green card they would change it
you gotta change it i can't
i can't you know how to use cards and he
was like oh
come on and whose lines anyway every
time they'd play the euphemism game
colin mockery is like great
god mark i do
you act like i had a choice you green
card plane oh you butter
stick eating backwards walking
cartoon watcher yeah that's right bob
give bob flashier
[Laughter]
what is this hand i had like four eights
last hand to start with so
you guys i don't think
take one of these you you rock sniffing
table licker yeah you're the one who
played the
the thing you that one wiping
poop stepper runner four card
taking card taker
you're really crushing it man you're
crushing it thanks oh
bob i've got another round of hate for
you you
you flat-footed listen oh pants where
whoa oh you
card get a guy to my left
fire over there really really good it's
really ripping them out
yeah i can jump in on my own card hey it
worked that time
i feel like somehow in this i'm so
scared of accidentally saying like
something
really horrible in this mixture i feel
like i'm
stepping on landmines here uh i have no
control it's not my fault it's not my
fault
you gave me this card that i
will pass on oh oh wait a minute hang on
sneaky brain okay that's right they
took cards well it didn't help me
accepted
uno you took the card
i'm jumping in all right
jumping in damn all right
you got that one no i'm good
wow great what a hand great why would
you do that
i had three plus fours from the start
now they all gone all gone
they all gone they're all gone they're
all gone well
licking dill herder oh boy
oh darn it wow well jeez
that's not even a good one red red okay
i don't know my color is very that red
okay you other
color changing color one there we go
i think we're all we can all enjoy that
i think you know what to do with it i
think you know what to do wade
i think you know what to do yes you
goat slapping oh no no no
obviously not wow this hand sucks even
more than that hand
i'm not sure what happened but it seems
like it worked out for me
oh hey look at that how did you draw
cards and then jump in on your own cards
because i already had the red four i
just wanted to get a seven or a zero get
rid of this
so you were drawing intentionally see
you're drawing on purpose just to be a
yeah well you know i didn't really
expect this to be the winning hand
stabbed him right in the throat yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait
not like this like this oh no listen
i can i'll play i reverse that at you
yeah
[Laughter]
i'm jumping in i'm playing an eight i'm
playing a zero
oh well that's okay it will be that's
about okay another one's probably coming
oh goodness me well that's okay i guess
oh great hand here a lot of numbers
thanks man
a lot of numbers
some threes wtf happened to elbow
nothing nothing happened almost fine ah
the one
color i don't have one
one
ah well it's not my thoughts out of my
hands out of my hands hey
that's an interesting turn of events you
are
a jerk hole you really ruined that for
everyone no no i was saved by the bear
okay still don't have red
thank you i know who my competition is
oh boy i
don't yeah i have one of them's i guess
yeah i get to play it too
oh girl come on
you absolute savage right now it's not
oh
okay well all right
get a mark all right well not me i'll be
here
if you need me okay
yeah that really worked out
um okay you know what i don't care
ah right wow that was nice of you kind
of huh
okay i thought wait
[Applause]
wait i even with all yeah
there's not even a three i know that
that that hand's
fine believe it keeps going back to red
that hand doesn't have any why are there
so many of them
but none of it wait okay
i accept this i forgot accept your
judgment sir
do not accept it
yeah yeah yeah okay all right yeah yeah
yeah oh
yeah yeah okay yay
evil and not
[Applause]
okay
was the one bob that's the one funny
about that that's the funny thing about
that that's the one
okay i'll draw it's fine all right
dude mark you were down to two cars
before weren't you sure was yeah yeah
you were too oh yeah
thanks man thank you thank you good i
know you like these greens i do
i do it's my favorite well it's not but
all right okay
i hate daddy god i
kind of deserved it but i didn't oh no
you know who deserves you pretty much
deserved it
wait why would you go for me
left footed mushroom wielder there now
you can insult now you can insult yeah
yeah now you can figure it out great
good good me the whole time
we're all so happy for you i don't have
any blue and i find that
look it's not my fault i didn't this is
there's some fishy
there's something about that i don't
trust that i don't trust you
okay i should have trusted you
it makes sense now you drew that one i
see that now yeah
what hang on i play a four against that
ah that didn't work
helpless oh boy oh you just need to take
it to the face
wow we got a lot of cards is there a
point to get
the cards have these cards all right
i dare you to play it on yourself
[Laughter]
look mark i want you to have the same
kind of photo all right
oh no oh thank you
yeah that's a four buddy you did it
thanks man
oh chopper you don't get to play after
you broke the rules of the game
a bit aggressive yeah i know i'm sorry i
should have been more like
hey chomper i'm sorry but i'm cutting
oh wow oh man i hate
you
daddy done lacking this game
[Laughter]
wait what game specifically is it that
you don't like oh
the game of changing hands with chomper
i feel like you've been unironically
calling yourself daddy a lot more lately
oh i've got something to tell you i'm
not a father
all right so cool daddy is just the
sexual term i want you to refer to me as
from now on
and i'm glad we demonetized
oh god damn it partisan oh
well that's rude oh that stinks
that's just oh i'm gonna challenge it
just because
it's so man only reds wow he's out only
red cards everyone
so spoiler alert you're ruining the
ending there you go mark that'll show
him you saved me stopper comes in oh
did i now oh what how did he get me
what you got destroyed shopper got me
oh no chopper's good
why is chomper good at this game not as
many rances
too that's not the way i meant to word
it
guys i had i had it in the bag guys
wait that's not my bag bob that's not my
bag that's your bag man
my bag i'm sorry no not this
yes yes everything is good now
wait reverse it i have a thing i can do
some stuff with
the cards that i have in my hand if you
reverse it chomper
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is kind of rude and i apologize
listen
i know what you're thinking oh man i
challenge you
to a duel sir my dueling weapon
that i won't show on camera has been out
this whole time
family friendly first your family
friendly dueling weapon
yes it is a why can't i jump in on that
a little hat where it's a little
okay it's a little hat yeah
um i could do something else no let me
crush let me crush chuck
god damn it i had a move oh okay
wow i have a move to cr this is what you
get bob
right now i was gonna crush chopper and
levels of
and this cardboard what it means to go
even put it blue put it blue wait put it
blue yes
put it back okay i'm not gonna do
anything this round you do okay
watch this see this aha
yeah see now watch now watch now watch
yeah see i've got no blue in
14 cards i have no blue
that is impressive i know right for how
many cards
i've lost my amounts of red oh god one
would
think for how many cards you do have
well that's
just rude bob there is zero red in this
hand i thought we were working together
a little bit watch the stream man i
could have done anything maybe
why me i don't have any i see what he's
going at i see what he's getting at here
my eyes got some moves guys bob bob take
a look at this hand just take a look at
it
well there's a problem you can't really
get around in that hand you just got
yourself there
here i'll let you get around it right
now
yeah pulls it out of the bag he's gonna
have to chomp on his own grave
soon right guys um probably yeah yeah
yeah bob that's not the color we wanted
we all right okay all right yeah
okay well listen chomper you're gonna
have something to
you have to do well yeah yeah chopper is
like real douchebag right now yeah yeah
i just have to do it right now let's see
you know let's see if they're gonna do
it right now
he's gotta he's got a whoa all right
um huh well that was my one trick i had
in the bag and now the bag is just full
of uh
garbage bags wait look at my bag did you
see that bag it's a nice bag that was a
good bag
that was like a reusable bag okay that
was rude okay make it yellow
yeah i would totally would do that for
you if i could no no for not for me make
chomper to play at seven he has to give
up his hand to one of us
sure yeah well if i had anything
slowly becoming absolute trash all right
good thing one of us has a good hand
around here
i'm gonna draw some more cards because i
want to
not because i don't have anything to
play that one
oh well maybe i'll play that that's fine
uh yeah well i'll take
this us thanks oh that's not the
direction i thought it was traveling
[Laughter]
i was doubly shocked by which hand i
ended up with and then what was in it
oh thanks buddy
my dude i hope you said
you're sure making me have to empty it
out okay i'll just keep
emptying the tank why back to yellow
i'll take your tank is happening
it's okay because i got my own trick
play
oh yeah before ah
sorry i was looking away
bob you want you want to jump in you're
getting do you have any blues wait
i don't think you have anything i do but
i'm doing this because i felt like it
not because i had to uh-huh
but you want to make sure you get the
right one you know yeah i wanted to make
sure i've got the
right oh i like this okay um that's an
option
that we had before um but it's not as
good of an option
bob you're not listening to me i am
listening okay all right
i will jump in oh no don't bob i didn't
have a choice
that's great with me so this is
wonderful bob what color you need
uh i mean i'd like to keep it okay
thanks for asking
[Laughter]
i was really generous of you and i know
you didn't have to do that
oh that
i feel bad i feel bad but hey
the fun of this game is playing it so
the longer you get to play it the more
fun you are
right okay true that is true hey now
listen i feel like
that is out of spite oh well that's not
what you want to see
hey wade i got a joke for you
you're gonna laugh
[Laughter]
no no no no no you don't get to you know
i'm what's happening
oh no mark why can't i okay yeah what's
up
you gotta jump in all right i will i'm
ready i'm ready i'll jump here we go
yeah uh-huh i got this
what got him all right mark you got to
jump in
all right buddy i'm ready pal i got this
here we go not like this okay all right
we'll just make it red and get over with
oh you think it's gonna be red oh you
silly fool it's gonna be
yellow okay that's uh that's okay with
me
mark what color do you want oh you know
i was thinking maybe we could do yellow
or
blue or red okay cool good good thank
you i got you i i'm a good
friend okay all right well i don't trust
you what
i drew that i listened and i do know i
just i'm not a psychopath
i'm going to give you this hand is is
what i'm going to literally would have
automatically won the round if i had the
color
no i'm gonna i know i'm i want more cars
to give you this
that's my strategy okay all right mark
you're ready uh yeah i'm gonna jump
here we go ready three's gonna happen
here we go
i can't jump oh well
uh uh yeah this is huh
it's true
[Music]
you